the Game of Thrones finale left a lot of
viewers asking questions and now some of
them have been answered thanks to the
release of the episode script here's a
look at some of the most surprising
small details uncovered in its pages
after the game of Thrones finale aired
fans hurried online to try and find an
answer to one huge lingering question
about the destruction of the Iron Throne
did Rogen intentionally destroy the Iron
Throne because he recognized it as the
reason for Daenerys downfall or was he
just a big dumb animal lashing out turns
out that big dragon is just a big dumb
animal in the script showrunners David
Benioff and DB Weiss wrote that Rogan
wanted to burn the world saying we look
over John's shoulder as the fire sweeps
toward the throne not the target of
dragons wrath just a dumb bystander
caught up in the conflagration so for
anyone looking for some kind of meaning
in these events there isn't any one
thing that chapped a lot of hides was
the fact that we never got a sense of
what Daenerys was feeling or thinking
after she went on her rampage in the
penultimate episode the finale script
unfortunately doesn't offer any insight
either from the moment Jon enters the
throne room and her final scene the
script doesn't give any hint of Danny's
point of view focusing entirely on Jon
Snow fans who were upset at Daenerys
lack of dialogue during the siege of
King's Landing probably won't be any
happier knowing the Dragon Queen didn't
even get an inner monologue while she
was being stabbed to death over the
course of the show Daenerys certainly
acquired plenty of lofty titles you
stand in the presence of Daenerys
Stormborn of House Targaryen rightful
heir to the Iron Throne rightful queen
of the Andals and the first men like a
lot of them protector of the Seven
Kingdoms the mother of dragons the
Khaleesi of the great grass sea the
unburnt the breaker of chains but while
many fans were calling her the Mad Queen
at the end just as her father before her
was the Mad King the script actually
gave her a more unexpected title during
the finale her satanic Majesty yep while
describing the scene retaining lords
over her conquered city the script read
for a moment dragons unfolding wings
spread behind her back an
settling image her satanic Majesties
request that's actually a reference to
the 1967 Rolling Stones album their
satanic Majesties request which contains
a lot of trippy imagery one of the most
haunting sequences in the Game of
Thrones finale is Terrance long walk
through the ruins of King's Landing
Benioff and Weiss deliberately packed
this part of the script with cultural
and historical references to give an
added the focus Ontarians face for
instance was inspired by the 2015
Holocaust drama son of Saul the script
read we follow him son of Saul style
tight on his face as he passes through
the gates and a few lines later the
directions reference another tragedy
from World War two the atomic bombing of
Hiroshima Japan on saying human
silhouettes on the Dragons scorched
ground where the ashes have blown away
the negative image of the Hiroshima
silhouettes one place the script does
provide important nuance is that weird
council meeting where the heads of the
noble families of Westeros somehow ended
up electing bran as king it seemed a bit
random to many fans but the script
provides some much-needed explanation as
to why the council voted that way that
mere telly brands uncle is miffed he
wasn't given serious consideration but
he expects he'll have influence at court
if his crippled nephew is ruling
meanwhile Gendry is quote happy to go
along while Yara Greyjoy has apparently
heard that her brother died defending
bran
she knows this choice would make Theon
happy finally Brienne of Tarth is quote
a stark loyalist one person who doesn't
get a lot of development that random new
Prince of Dorne who is such a nonentity
that even the script doesn't bother
giving him a name sorry whoever you are
if you thought it was weird that bran
became king well why isn't Benioff
agreed as the script itself noted more
than once how odd this plot twist was
remember when Tyrion offered him the
crown do you wear the crown why do you
think I came all this way in the script
it then said a strange response but
Tyrion has come to expect strange
answers from bran
then in the small council meeting after
asking where drogon is brand drops this
perhaps I can find him in the script
this is followed by a note reading
that's weird but so is the new king also
weird the fact that Sam is wearing grand
maester robes even though he never
completed his training but the script
makes it clear that he is indeed a grand
maester despite his eliminate
qualifications when sam enters the small
council chamber the script notes he
wears the grand maester robes and a
chain with a single healing link at
least someone in the show got a happy
ending at the end of the show Jon Snow
was exiled to the far north as he
rejoins the Nights Watch we end the
series with John and his wildling
friends wandering past the wall
considering there seems to be no reason
to even have a Night's Watch anymore
that led some fans to think he was
taking his place as the
king-beyond-the-wall
but the script seems to suggest he's
just a regular Schmo as it unequivocally
calls him a night's watchman
rather than a king considering the fate
of most monarchs on the show though
that's probably for the best check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bells
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]